[Aplausos]
[Música]
venezuela la deva que en este país
latinoamericano parece que va camino de
eternizarse y es que lejos de mejorar la
situación no hace más que ir a peor a
peor ya peor el pib venezolano cayó en
2019 en torno a un 35 por ciento si no
me equivocado un 35 por ciento tan sólo
en los últimos seis años el país ha
perdido dos terceras partes de su
riqueza
en otras palabras hablamos de un
hundimiento que no tiene prácticamente
precedentes históricos en todo el mundo
sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que no
es el caso de un país que técnicamente
esté en guerra y amigos tal y como ya os
hemos contado en alguna que otra ocasión
uno de los grandes motivos de este
fracaso estrepitoso del sistema político
y económico bolivariano tiene que ver
con su altísima dependencia del petróleo
porque si durante años cuando el crudo
estaba más de 100 dólares el barril
hugo chávez y sus acólitos pudieron
permitirse dispendios de todo tipo
podían casi impunemente perseguir
ahuyentar y castigar a la inversión
privada e incluso a pesar de ello ir con
la cabeza alta presumiendo de cierta
prosperidad sin embargo desde entonces
las cosas han cambiado mucho a peor y
ahora en 2020 la crisis de coronavirus
ha sido la puntilla
para una industria la del petróleo
venezolano que como veremos lleva años
haciendo aguas quedaros con este dato el
barril de petróleo venezolano se vendió
a 99 dólares en abril de este 2011
frente a los casi 57 dólares de mediados
que se comercializó en 2019 y ojo porque
esto no es lo peor
échale un vistazo a este gráfico que nos
muestra cómo ha evolucionado la
producción petrolera de venezuela
durante los últimos 10 años
amigos a pesar de tener las reservas de
petróleo más grandes de todo el mundo el
desastre de las políticas bolivarianas
ha sido de tal magnitud que hoy
venezuela produce aproximadamente 6
veces menos petróleo que hace apenas 6
años en 2020 los ingresos del crudo
serán más de un 95 por ciento más
pequeños que los de hace apenas 6 años y
no olvidéis ni por un instante que
hablamos de una economía que se
desarrolló con un modelo básicamente
rentista el gobierno bolivariano no
utilizó nunca los inmensos recursos que
obtuvo con la venta de petróleo para no
se desarrollar o diversificar su
economía ni siquiera invirtieron en la
propia industria que era su gallina de
los huevos de oro resulta difícil de
creer pero la producción de petróleo
comenzó a caer cuando los precios
estaban por las nubes
y no hablamos de la extracción de
petróleo sino también de su refinamiento
es decir el proceso por el cual se
transforma el crudo en combustible para
poder ser usado y aquí los números no
son mejores de hecho lo cierto es que
son peores durante las últimas dos
décadas la capacidad de refinamiento de
venezuela no ha hecho más que caer la
falta de inversión mantenimiento y la
haber sustituida profesionales por miles
de amiguetes sin competencia en
información especializada ha hecho que
las refinerías venezolanas hayan sufrido
durante los últimos años un montón de
accidentes averías incendios que poco a
poco han ido reduciendo la capacidad de
refinamiento venezolana hasta llevarla
prácticamente a cero
[Música]
de hecho este 2020 comenzó con noticias
como estas pero esa tierra sus dos
últimas refinerías operativas en
venezuela- amuay cardón si lo habéis
oído bien la otra ahora gran potencia
del sector industrial petrolero se ha
visto obligado a cerrar sus complejos
incluida la joya de la corona la
refinería de amuay la base de la que
lleva a ser uno de los tres complejos
para refinar petróleo más grandes de
todo el planeta y no no penséis que lo
han hecho para luchar contra el cambio
climático ni nada por el estilo los
incendios las averías los cortes de
electricidad e incluso la falta de
petróleo es lo que finalmente han
obligado a gobierno venezolano a echar
el cierre y eso eso es lo que explica
que en un país que literalmente flota en
petróleo nos encontremos con noticias
como esta pero irán y llega venezuela
desafiando a eeuu y la pregunta es y
ahora que es decir qué va a hacer ahora
del gobierno bolivariano si ya no es
capaz de extraer y refinar el petróleo
mínimo que necesita la economía
venezolana para funcionar como van a
tratar de mantener ahora su revolución
de dónde van a sacar los recursos que
necesitan para seguir sobornando a todos
los saltos gerifaltes del ejército y del
gobierno para que sigan siendo leales
pues amigos justo aquí es donde entra en
juego la que puede ser la última
el gobierno bolivariano de nicolás
maduro
venezuela tiene una región conocida como
el arco minero del orinoco que podría
contar con una de las mayores riquezas
minerales de todo el mundo según los
datos del gobierno venezolano esta
región albergaría siete mil toneladas de
oro lo que por cierto la convertiría en
la segunda mayor reserva del mundo
millones de toneladas de kimberley té y
diamantes hierro bauxita y otros 40
minerales de alto valor incluido el
coltán hoy por hoy uno de los minerales
más apreciados en la industria
electrónica si estas cifras fueran
reales cual no parece descabellado y
lograsen explotar su potencial de forma
regular venezuela podría ingresar miles
y miles de millones de dólares cada año
dólares que por supuesto llegado el caso
podrían emplearse a restaurar la propia
industria petrolera el precario sistema
eléctrico nacional el tratamiento y la
distribución de agua o los planes para
industrializar y desarrollar la economía
venezolana en otras palabras llegado el
momento el arco minero del orinoco
podría jugar un papel clave en la
recuperación de venezuela
claro que un momento porque con la
realidad nos hemos topado cuál es el
problema pues que estas regiones mineras
son de todo menos tranquilas y apacibles
zonas para hacer negocios más bien todo
lo contrario amigos queréis saber más
sobre toda esta historia pues allá vamos
la fiebre del oro a ver si algo
caracteriza al gobierno venezolano es
que no les gusta dejar títere con cabeza
todo todo lo que suponga una potencial
fuente de riqueza o la roba o la ex
propia planta guarenas después se planta
lara
exprópiese planta de electrosoldado
valencia
exprópiese y el sector minero no iba a
ser menos ahora bien cuál es el metal
que hoy por hoy más le interesa al
gobierno chavista bingo seguro que
muchos lo habéis acertado el oro
[Aplausos]
y es que los amigos no solo es escaso
sino que es uno de los pocos minerales
por no decir prácticamente el único que
tiene un alto valor nada mas extraerse
es decir incluso sin haber sido
procesado de hecho el normativo que es
como se conoce y al oro sin refinar
tiene tanto valor que es más codiciado
que una piruleta en la puerta de un
colegio precisamente por eso el gobierno
venezolano ya en tiempos de chávez tuvo
entre sus principales objetivos
controlar su producción distribución y
venta un objetivo que lo llevó a
expropiar entre el año 2008 y el año
2011 un montón de concesiones en manos
de empresas mineras privadas sobre todo
de empresas canadienses algo que por
cierto le costó al gobierno venezolano
ser condenado por un tribunal de
arbitraje internacional claro que eso en
caracas es casi como recibir un corazón
púrpura o una medalla al mérito militar
ya sabéis es la lucha contra el
imperialismo pero os hago una pregunta
cuál pensáis que fue el resultado en
términos de producción pues si la
producción de oro se desplomó un 80 por
ciento en apenas tres años lo esperado
vaya el gobierno bolivariano ha tenido
la capacidad de destrozar todo lo que
toca no obstante un momento antes de
editar sentencia porque las cosas han
cambiado algo en los últimos años entre
otras cosas porque el gobierno de maduro
sabe que el oro es
una de sus últimas bajadas para
aferrarse al poder o mejor dicho para
continuar saqueando el país impunemente
durante los últimos años el gobierno de
maduro ha firmado acuerdos con compañías
mineras sobre todo rusas y chinas y en
2015 aprobó el decreto 2.165 que permite
la reincorporación de empresas privadas
en el sector eso sí a través de una
empresa mixta con el estado y siempre
con la condición de que al menos el 55
por ciento de esa empresa esté bajo
control del gobierno de esta manera el
estado quiere seguir controlando la
producción al tiempo que logra hacerse
con la experiencia de las empresas
mineras al menos de aquellas que se
atreven a entrar en esta arriesgada
aventura además recientemente en abril
del 2020 se legalizó la explotación de
minas de oro en áreas fluviales que
hasta ahora era una actividad prohibida
porque implica un daño altísimo al medio
ambiente pero maduro maduro ahora quiere
necesita oro sea como sea y cuanto más
mejor
[Música]
sobre el papel puede no sonar tan raro
pero amigos ojo porque hay un ligero
problema la mayoría de las explotaciones
de minerales y sobre todo las de oro son
ilegales y están en manos de grupos
criminales y de traficantes que en
muchos casos no son precisamente afines
al gobierno
se cree que hay operando en torno a 2000
minas de este tipo y ojo porque no
penséis que hablamos de cualquier cosa
la minería ilegal llevada a cabo por
grupos no afines al gobierno representa
hoy por hoy una buena parte de la
producción de oro en el país si es que
no es la mayor parte estas minas
controladas por grupos y clanes
delincuentes han convertido al estado
bolívar que es donde se encuentra
mayoritariamente el arco minero del
orinoco en una región prácticamente en
guerra grupo es como el de jon valdez
alias el toto se han convertido en uno
de los mayores enemigos del gobierno al
haber conseguido poner contra las
cuerdas al ejército al ln y a
guerrilleros de las farc si si habéis
escuchado bien al lm y a la ex farc
estos grupos guerrilleros que antaño
fueron puramente colombianos se han
convertido ahora en bandas criminales de
traficantes colombo-venezolanas con las
que el gobierno chavista colabora
abiertamente por ejemplo para que os
hagáis una idea se calcula que de todos
los ingresos por actividades ilícitas
que obtiene ln el 60 por ciento procede
de la minería ilegal en venezuela y ojo
también en colombia sobre de todo esto y
más os vamos a hablar en unos instantes
porque lo cierto es que mucha pero que
mucha mucha tela que cortar pero antes
antes vamos a darle un repaso a cómo
funciona la producción de oro en
venezuela ya qué papel juega en toda
esta historia del banco
del país atentos
y venezolana establece que toda la
producción de oro debe ser entregada al
banco central de venezuela que gestiona
las reservas de oro y las exportaciones
del oro extraído para ser comercializado
además para exportar este mineral se
necesita que la operación sea aprobada
por la asamblea nacional un
requerimiento legal que el gobierno
chavista se salta desde que el
parlamento venezolano cayó en manos de
la oposición pero el mayor problema es
que debido a las gigantescas redes de
contrabando y minería ilegal que sacan
el oro de venezuela sobre todo a través
de brasil y guyana se calcula que sólo
uno de cada tres o cuatro toneladas
extraídas se entregan al banco central
venezolano con lo que el estado pierde
el control sobre la mayor parte del
comercio del oro y también por supuesto
sobre sus ingresos por eso el gobierno
chavista de nicolás maduro ha declarado
la guerra a la minería ilegal pero no
para terminar con ella sino
esencialmente para restaurar su poder y
hacerse con esa actividad o con otras
palabras la idea no es solucionar el
problema sino sustituir a los
protagonistas
y aquí es cuando llega la parte más fea
de la historia los estados mineros en
especial el estado bolívar se han
convertido en una especie de anarquía
violenta donde los criminales del
gobierno y los criminales del
contrabando se matan unos a otros por el
control un escenario terrible que está
provocando salvajes que matanzas como
las que estamos acostumbrados a ver por
la televisión o en películas de
hollywood y entre cuyas víctimas
encontramos a mineros de uno y otro
bando a colaboradores a transportistas y
por supuesto a todo tipo de mercenarios
y cabecillas amigos os venís con
nosotros a este lugar para saber más
sobre lo que está pasando y hacia dónde
se está inclinando la balanza pues
empecemos
[Música]
el oro de sangre os lo hemos contado el
gobierno venezolano y los guerrilleros
del eln y las farc han generado una
curiosa simbiosis criminal para hacerse
con el control del oro en el orinoco y
si la presencia de estos grupos
criminales ya pinta el panorama de negro
imagina si la ecuación le añadimos el
componente de los militares corruptos
especialmente de los altos oficiales
corruptos militares que en lugar de
trabajar para garantizar que el oro y
sus beneficios pues mejoren la situación
económica del país se dedican a llenarse
el bolsillo y que no tienen reparos en
trabajar y colaborar con bandas
criminales pues amigos eso es
exactamente lo que está ocurriendo según
se sabe los métodos que los militares se
emplean para llenarse los bolsillos en
este particular ecosistema criminal son
equivalentes a los que utilizan los
guerrilleros del eln y la sexual que
cobran una especie de peajes en forma de
oro coltán diamantes o lo que sea que se
extraiga algo así como un impuesto en
especial los grupos ilegales que se
encargan de extraer el mineral y ya
sabes si no pasas por el aro pues adiós
bye bye van a por ti y entonces la
guerra está servida pero ojo porque no
creéis que estos son los únicos
protagonistas la mismísima empresa
minera estatal por excelencia de
venezuela minervén está
metida de lleno en toda esta turbia
historia
esta empresa que está sancionada por
eeuu por enriquecer ilegalmente a maduro
y la cúpula chavista ha pasado de
extraer por ella misma el oro a ser un
mero canalizador del oro ilegal ahora la
mayor parte del oro que minervén hace
llegar al banco central de venezuela
para venderlo o sacarlo del país procede
de las extracciones realizadas por
grupos criminales que controla el
gobierno
[Música]
es decir para que nos entendamos en
venezuela- la extracción de muchos
minerales y sobre todo del oro ya no
depende ni del gobierno ni de
concesiones ni de empresas privadas sino
simple y llanamente de grupos ilegales
esto es lo que ha convertido venezuela a
la revolución bolivariana pero en valor
no nos expresemos volvamos al oro que
consigue controlar el gobierno
venezolano y que se ha convertido en su
última gran fuente de ingresos
el caso es que debido a las sanciones
internacionales las opciones que el
gobierno venezolano tiene para
exportarlo también se han reducido
considerablemente por ejemplo antes
buena parte de lo normativo era enviado
a suiza para ser refinado antes de ser
vendido o depositado en las arcas del
banco central pero ahora todas las
sanciones estadounidenses y el país
helvético se ha desentendido de esta
actividad y ya no aceptaste oro algo que
ha obligado a los gerifaltes venezolanos
a cambiar sus rutas hoy el oro que
consigue exportar el gobierno venezolano
es enviado a lugares como turquía dubai
o uganda si se pagan 273 toneladas de
oro de venezuela volaron a turquía dubai
uganda de hecho según informaciones de
insightcrime se cree que el oro
venezolano podría estar saliendo del
país en vuelos regulares de turkish
airlines la mayor aerolínea turca que
vuela entre el aeropuerto de maiquetía y
el de estambul vuelos que se iniciaron
en 2016 con tres frecuencias semanales y
que apenas un año después se ampliaron a
cinco sospechosos pero qué pasa después
que pasa una vez que el oro llega a
turquía
pues después parece ser que buena parte
de los lingotes de oro ya refinados
acaban a buen resguardo en irán un fiel
aliado del régimen venezolano o
depositados en bancos de singapur muchas
de estas operaciones claros son
enmarcadas como ventas a empresas de
dudosa reputación y sirven bien para
llenarse los bolsillos o bien para pagar
los suministros y provisiones que el
gobierno venezolano necesita para
mantenerse en el poder pero no sólo se
utiliza a turquía uganda se ha
convertido en otro destino prioritario
aquí el oro venezolano lo refina la
african gold reef hainer y una empresa
que pertenece a la sociedad belga ghost
world con sede en dubai
[Música]
turquía uganda dubai menudo tinglado por
cierto esta empresa belga es sospechosa
de formar parte de una red de tráfico
internacional de oro de sangre que es
como se conocía el oro extraído
ilegalmente en zonas de conflicto bélico
o por cuyo comercio y control hay
disputas armadas entre grupos criminales
vamos justo lo que está pasando en el
arco minero del orinoco
[Música]
y lo peor es que todas estas
transacciones millonarias los
venezolanos prácticamente no ven nada
porque amigos amigas de visual político
tristemente la mayor parte del oro que
sale del país con el pretexto de
refinarlo nunca vuelve ni se ingresa de
nuevo en el banco central de venezuela
ni en forma de lingotes ni tampoco en
forma de dólares simplemente desaparece
a donde irá a parar seguro seguro que ya
sabéis por dónde van los tiros y luego
no olvidéis que entre las dos terceras y
las tres cuartas partes de toda la
producción de oro es decir la mayor
parte de la producción de oro no está
controlada por el gobierno no al menos
mediante los cauces que fija la ley es
decir la corrupción del régimen chavista
y el descontrol del estado sobre los
contrabandistas hacen que los
venezolanos estén perdiendo cientos y
cientos de toneladas de oro cientos y
cientos miles de millones de dólares que
son extraídos impunemente del país una
fortuna amigos que no sólo no está
creando riqueza en venezuela sino que
incluso está bañando el país de sangre y
no sólo se trata del oro con los
diamantes o el coltán venezolano está
ocurriendo algo parecido y por supuesto
de la otra fuente de ingreso de gobierno
el narcotráfico ya ni hablemos os lo
contamos ya en este vídeo
amigos la revolución bolivariana ha
convertido a venezuela en un gran estado
mafioso y ahora ahora el propio gobierno
bolivariano se encuentra contra las
cuerdas porque ya ni siquiera es capaz
de controlar a los grupos criminales que
operan en el país y la pregunta es
llegado el momento creéis que venezuela
podrá aprovechar todas estas inmensas
riquezas para salir adelante tiene
solución a la corrupción
institucionalizada y el crimen
organizado en el país podría haber
llegado ya venezuela a una especie de
punto sin retorno como siempre en
nuestras horas preguntas y vuestras las
respuestas así que no olvidéis dejarnos
vuestra opinión aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
resultó interesante no olvidéis
hacérnoslo saber dándole al botón de
like suscribiéndose a visual polític si
es que aún no lo habéis hecho y dándole
a la campanita para estar al tanto de
todas nuestras actualizaciones una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]